algunos pisoteados la mayoría asfixiados
cuando los hinchas del arema FC
derrotados invadieron el terreno de
juego frustrados por una derrota por 3 a
2 se enfrentaron a las fuerzas del orden
la aficionados y policías se culpan de
la tragedia
muchos de nuestros amigos perdieron la
vida por culpa de los oficiales que no
nos humanizaron estamos muy
decepcionados con el trato porque se
perdieron muchas vidas
la policía ya había tomado medidas
preventivas antes de disparar los gases
lacrimógenos estaban atacando a la
policía actuando anárquicamente y
quemando vehículos
los partidos de la Liga Indonesia se
suspendieron hasta una nueva
investigación según las normas FIFA la
policía no puede portar ni armas de
fuego ni gases durante un partido
mientras que se abrían vendido 4.000
entradas más de las permitidas que el
presidente ordenó una investigación
Lamento esta tragedia y espero que sea
la última que ocurra en el fútbol
indonesio no podemos tener más en el
futuro la deportividad la humanidad y la
hermandad en la nación deben mantenerse
juntas
una violencia habitual Indonesia Tiene
un gran historial de desórdenes en
partidos de fútbol por lo que los
equipos visitantes no pueden comprar
entradas pese a esto Este es el peor
desastre futbolístico en más de medio
siglo el más mortal fue el de 1964 en
Perú cuando murieron 328 personas tras
un motín y un aplastamiento